joining me now who's someone's been all
over this issue Senator Marco Rubio Vice
chair of the Intel committee and a
senior member of the Foreign Relations
Committee Senator
um given Hunter's well-documented
business connections to China he
received an enormous amount of money
from that Chinese energy interest and
the fact that Biden has been tied to
some of those transactions
is it fair to at least ask the question
do any of our dealings including this
one with China need to be scrutinized
further given these uh conflicts
well I think we need to follow those
those roads wherever they take us and if
in fact it can be proven or at least
shown that any of those business
dealings and return are now influencing
policy we would want to know about that
everybody deserves to know about it I
think that would be criminal if that
were the case but what's pretty clear is
Hunter Biden made a lot of money for a
guy that has no qualifications I mean
just common sense tells you you don't
pay people the amount of money he made
not just from China from Ukraine you
know gifts from uh even from Russians
all this kind of thing for a guy that's
completely inqualified to get that kind
of money and then the way the money was
distributed through a series of
Byzantine shell companies under the name
of in some cases kids that were barely
adults or in some cases minors I mean if
that if there was an R next to the Biden
name this would be the number one story
in America but instead you know they've
tried as long as probably up until today
to keep all this under the rug and not
really focus on I think it's going to be
hard after today for the media not to
focus on it because now that was a court
hearing now there was a judge now there
was a plea deal that was rejected
because of how outrageous it was and now
there was a mention of other ancillary
investigations alongside this one so I
just ask people to be fair about this
think about it for a moment if the Biden
name had an R next to its name a
republican where we would be today on
the story would be the dominant story in
America there'd be Netflix documentaries
about it already
right they would already have the
chirons and the special Graphics
packages done Senator
um but just back to policy whether it's
our policy in Ukraine where just a few
years ago Joe Biden was claiming that
that Donald Trump had side business
deals in Ukraine he was actually
speculating on that a few years ago
projecting perhaps what was going on
with his own family because Hunter Biden
was getting a lot of money from
Ukrainian interests that's documented by
the the house actions so meanwhile we
you know we're obviously in a proxy war
right now in Ukraine and China policy
all of it is called into question I mean
you have Financial benefits going to the
Biden family from these business
interests they're going to the Biden
family well I think more than just and
we're supposed to just say oh well yeah
yeah so I think more than just the I
think sometimes people would think to
themselves well they paid him all this
money so now in return you're going to
do something nice for them I think we
need to think about what other
information if you've paid Hunter Biden
all this money whether you're a Chinese
company Ukrainian company
what if this is compromising information
this is the kind of thing that you could
back Channel hey you know we're going to
release this stuff if you push too hard
or you don't do what we want you to do
in policy front I mean understand when
you do deals with these people these
people have like whatever Ukrainian
business interest Hunter Biden was
involved in these people have documents
they've got more information than we
have right now and I'm sure they
threatened if that's the case to provide
it publicly and create real problems for
the president that's tremendous amount
of Leverage to have over a political
figure that's why things like this have
to be revealed
and Senator uh talk hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else